-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Paul Bettany.
Your costar, Jeremy Pope,
an incredibly talented actor
as well.
Does he get the sense you think
this whole thing is a nightmare
or --
-[ Laughs ]
You know, the truth
is working with Jeremy,
we've been doing this in
different iterations
with the film
and we did it in London.
It -- He -- It --
Working with Jeremy
is as close as you can get
to flying in your dreams.
It's just, when you're tired and
you don't want to do the show,
he comes on
and I look at him and he's --
he's just extraordinary.
It's been a real privilege
to work with him.
The kid's a genius.
-That's fantastic.
Another collaboration,
you're coming up
on a 20-year anniversary.
-Oh, yeah.
-You and your beautiful
charming wife,
Jennifer Connelly,
January 1st, I guess...
-Yes.
-...is 20 years.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-20 years.
-Wow.
-Yeah, which in Hollywood years
is like --
-Hollywood years, yeah.
-Like 80.
-It's very impressive.
And yet I would imagine,
due to your schedule,
you really can't do much, right?
With your theater schedule?
-Oh, God, that's true, yeah.
No, yeah.
Yes, this is an entire disaster.
[ Laughter ]
They make you work.
They make you work on,
like, holidays and stuff.
-Yeah.
-Like lure a first responder
or something.
[ Laughter ]
The whole thing's ridiculous.
You know, it's been --
it's been 20 --
it's been 20 years.
We've -- It's been wonderful,
and we've really
got to know each other.
[ Laughter ]
Now.
And -- You know, the amazing
thing about it is --
How long have you been married?
-Coming up on 10.
-Okay, well -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think -- I think
in like three years.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but not --
not as good as 20.
-No, no.
Of course not.
-Whatever.
Anyway, the thing
that's amazing about it,
being married 20 years,
is that my wife is still
utterly fascinated by me.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, she finds me fascinating.
And I can tell.
You know, we'll be at --
you know, having dinner
or whatever,
I'll be talking
about the news or my career.
Mostly my career.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Obviously.
And she is sometimes
so fascinated
that she takes her food and
she eats it in the other room.
[ Laughter ]
Presumably to ruminate
on all the amazing things
I just --
-Yeah, just like unpack
everything you just told her.
-Right.
So that's -- that's what being
married for 20 years feels like.
-That's really lovely.
You -- You know, obviously you
have a lot of holiday tourists
that I'm assuming are in town
to come see your show,
but you also had the privilege
of some high schoolers
came to see your show.
-Yes, yes.
I -- What a feral bunch.
[ Laughter ]
They -- They were -- Yeah.
So we did this -- So we --
Yeah, we did this show for --
for schoolkids.
And --
-So you know,
this is the schoolkids day.
-Yes.
-You're prepared in advance.
Okay.
-Yes.
And they laugh
every time you swear.
They laugh -- Then there's
this moment in the show
where I have to
take my shirt off.
Right?
And they lost their [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
I mean, just lost their [bleep].
And then what happened
was Jeremy Pope
then takes his shirt off.
And I noticed
they wolf whistled for him.
-So it was like funny
when your shirt came off.
-Yeah, no,
that's exactly the point.
Yeah, they found it hilarious
when I took my shirt off.
And then it was just quiet
except for endless wolf
whistles.
So this whole process
of doing this on Broadway
is just humiliating.
[ Laughter ]
It's been --
frankly, it's been --
You know, I think it's been
a hard year for everybody,
but mostly me.
-Yeah, yeah. I think --
I think, you know, everybody's
New Year's resolution
should be hoping
that you have a better 2023.
-I'm sure that's already
what they're thinking.
-You know what, I'm sorry,
I hate to continue
with a hammer on the things
that have gone wrong for you,
but Jennifer was in
"Top Gun: Maverick"
which has done very well
at the box office.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it is now -- it is now the
sixth highest grossing movie.
And in order to go from seventh
to sixth,
it passed "Avengers:
Infinity War" which you were in.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Yes.
-Now you, by with way,
you posted this and did say,
if we can come over here,
"I'm just never going to live
this down in the house."
Is that --
-That's true.
-Is she really just sort of
taking a victory lap on this?
-Yes, and I'm allowing her to,
because what she doesn't know,
it's just a lull in hostilities.
-Right.
-I have texted Kevin Feige.
He says, "I'm on it."
[ Light laughter ]
-Right.
-"We're going to take back
the mantle for you."
-There's more "Avengers" stuff
coming.
-Oh, yeah.
-All you have to do is be in it
for a little bit
for it to count.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's a fair point.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
I cannot wait to see the show.
And have a happy new year
and happy anniversary.
Always a pleasure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paul Bettany, everybody.
"The Collaboration" opens
December 20th
at Manhattan Theatre Club,
Samuel J. Friedman Theatre.
For more information, go to
manhattantheatreclub.com.
We'll be right back
with Lily Collins.